vous avez pas violer une fille avec des
copains dans les corons non
le fantasme
alors
c'est 20 ans qu'on fait de la télé on
n'avait jamais vu Frédéric François il
fallait pas eu déjà une femme
ce soir mais je connais ta gueule je
t'ai déjà vu quelque part
c'est vrai
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi c'est pareil mon cœur
qu'est-ce que tu croyais comme elle est
embrasser sur la bouche
[Applaudissements]
Olivier
sur le cul il y a
aucun problème
Frédéric François bonsoir bonsoir alors
votre nouvel album s'appelle et si on
parlait d'amour d'habitude vous parlez
d'amour et si on parlait d'amour on
parlait pas de foot en fait et si on
parlait d'amour par rapport à l'époque
où nous vivons je pense que c'est une
époque très chahutée et je pense que
plus que jamais les chansons d'amour ont
leur place et donc
parmi tous ces problèmes et ce monde qui
tourne à l'envers et si on parlait
d'amour ça serait la même chose
comment vous y avez pas pensé à ça je
suis d'accord avec ça
quand même
il commence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais nous on sait pourquoi ouais nous on
sait pourquoi on va parler de votre vie
la légende de Frédéric François c'est
une très très belle histoire que je vais
vous raconter Francesco barakato est né
en Sicile en 1950 un an plus tard en
compagnie de votre mère Nina et de votre
frère Rosario vous partez en Belgique
pour rejoindre guzep di pépino votre
père qui travaille à la mine depuis 5
ans voilà vous arrivez gardez Guillemins
à Liège au cœur du bassin Houyet on nous
a mis dans dans le camp c'était un camp
de qui servait aux prisonniers allemands
qui travaillait dans dans la mine et on
a occupé le camp il y avait un grand mur
ceinturé comme ça il y avait le
charbonnage et puis tout le campement le
camp qu'on appelait et avec un robinet
encore à l'extérieur les femmes allaient
laver le linge aussi à l'extérieur et
nous vivions dans communauté dans dans
le baraquement et donc on a attendu la
première maison 6 ans la deuxième si
ouais jusqu'à ce que le plafond nous
tombe sur la tête et puis on a eu
finalement une maison de la commune où
on a pu avoir une maison récente alors
de la Sicile votre père guscept est à
garder son son goût des chansons et
qu'il vous transmet il y a comme milieu
de au milieu de la fumée au milieu du
charbon il y avait cette espèce de rayon
de soleil qui était les chansons
napolitaines de votre père et bien
particulier qui a émigré avec sa guitare
en fait et bientôt vous il vous met
quand il va au bistrot il vous met sur
une table et vous fait chanter quoi très
jeune il disait à tous ses copains
d'Haïti
sur la table et je chantais en sole mur
et donc c'était sa fierté en fait et
très vite il disait tout ses copains moi
mon fils je vais en faire une star
attention vous habitons géographiquement
près du charbonnage avec des maisons de
la mine et des atout ses copains on va
devenir des stars c'était une mission
impossible alors en tous les cas 12 ans
vous achetez votre première guitare avec
votre livret de Caisse d'Épargne il y a
13 ans faites partie d'un premier groupe
qui s'appelle les Éperviers à 15 ans un
autre groupe qui s'appelle les tigres
sauvages et à 16 ans et là c'est
extraordinaire parce que malgré ces
maigres ressources et les 8 enfants
votre père vous inscrit au Conservatoire
de Musique de la Ville de Liège
exactement pour lui c'est génial parce
que c'est la certitude que vous n'irez
jamais à la mine c'est sorti de ça il
vous a sauvé de ça finalement en fait
chaque fois qu'il parlait il disait
toujours mes enfants ici personne ne
descendra jamais dans cette mine et
c'est vrai que ces économies ils les a
ils les a sacrifiés pour m'acheter une
sono pour m'acheter un micro pour jouer
la Presario c'est lui qui allait trouver
tous ces orchestres dans lequel je
rentrais en fait et un jour de de balles
en bas de radio crochets de petits
concours on a gagné un premier prix qui
s'appelait le micro sillon d'argent au
Festival de Châtelet Châtelet c'est près
de Charleroi c'était votre premier votre
premier succès là alors voilà je fais ce
concours je gagne le premier prix et
dans le jury il y avait
qui s'appelait Bob Jacquemin qui faisait
partie de l'orchestre de Ré Ventura et
il m'a fait enregistrer un disque le
seul problème c'est que il fallait
acheter les disques et donc avec mon
père on a acheté les disques les amis
dans des jukebox en les envoyant en
Sicile dans dans chez des copains mais
tente à mes cousines et puis voilà quoi
ça s'est arrêté là alors ce premier dit
c'était sur le nom de François Bara
parce que Barakat au barrage voilà
l'histoire a commencé en 1970 Lucien
Maurice vous fait enregistrer votre
premier disque en français puis là après
c'est le succès c'est l'époque des c'est
les chanteurs à l'époque avec les
cheveux longs l'école pointu les talents
et en fait tous ces chanteurs qui sont
arrivés en même temps sortaient de la
pomme musique et voilà que c'est un
style tout à fait à l'opposé parce que
c'était des chansons romantiques et
c'est devenu les chanteurs à minettes en
fait voilà parce que les filles étaient
comme les boys bandes devant la scène
elle hurlait à tout casser c'était
formidable alors voilà c'est une
histoire assez exemplaire le petit
sicilien comme ça qui vient en Belgique
qui arrive tout seul et même votre
histoire d'amour est assez exemplaire
parce que Monique en fait la femme que
vous allez épouser avec qui vous êtes
toujours aujourd'hui avec qui vous avez
4 enfants ben elle a grandi à Tilleur en
face de en face de chez vous je
connaissais ma femme depuis très
longtemps elle faisait partie de d'une
bande et moi j'avais pas les moyens de
faire partie de ces bandes parce qu'il
fallait aller au cinéma ils allaient
danser et moi je passais par là avec mon
violon j'allais en conservatoire et donc
je me devais de d'arriver à quelque
chose quoi et un jour en face de chez
moi il y avait un petit muret et c'est
là vu que j'allais au conservatoire et
j'avais toutes les après-midi de prise
de conservatoire je commençais à écrire
des chansons avec un mec qui habitait en
face de chez moi qui s'appelait
marinoatria et je jouais sur ce petit
muret des chansons et puis cette fille
que je connaissais depuis longtemps est
arrivée
est arrivé et elle m'a invité à aller ça
s'appelait la GC la Jeunesse Ouvrière
catholique elle m'a dit on paye pas si
tu veux c'est rien à faire on va là-bas
on va danser ce sera sympa et je suis
allé alors il y a eu un moment où
c'était un petit peu plus difficile
c'est dans les années 80 quand j'ai eu
l'arrivée du disco pour vous c'était
quand même la traversée du désert à un
moment mais c'est-à-dire que vous avez
été obligé de vendre votre maison de
Vallauris oui dur oui mais un peu
dépression quand même non pire encore
parce que bon une maison ça c'est
matériel mais quand on espère depuis des
années avec un père avec une famille
avec tout un contexte en face de ce
charbonnage et qu'on se dit un jour on
réussira et voilà que ça arrive moi je
pensais que on était chanteur à vie quoi
ma journaliste comme je sais pas moi
c'est un métier et donc là c'était une
mode en fait après les 5 ans le disco
est arrivé et tout le monde a été balayé
et donc moi je
plus sensible plus fragile dans le
subconscient j'ai dû enregistrer que que
ça ne fonctionnait plus on me demandait
de ne plus chanter des chansons d'amour
de changer de style de me mettre à la
mode ce que j'ai pas voulu faire et
petit à petit j'ai sombré dans une
maladie saloperie de maladie qui
s'appelle la spasmophilie au début
j'étais un malade imaginaire pour les
médecins jusqu'au jour où je tremble
tais ou c'est quoi alors ça se traduit
comment et bien ça commençait par les
bras qui devenaient
comme ça engourdit comme ça très dur les
lèvres et puis
plus aucune envie des mains qui
tremblent une plante voilà j'ai dû faire
une thérapie sur moi-même pour dire
voilà à partir d'aujourd'hui tu n'es
plus Frédéric François tu redeviens un
Francisco barakato tu as la chance de ta
vie tu as une belle famille tu as une
femme tu as tout ce qu'il faut le reste
n'a aucune importance donc vous avez
vendu votre maison de valorise quand
même c'est pas rien vous avez plus de
blé à l'époque quoi ça marchait plus du
tout fini
et alors là ce qui est incroyable un
jour tu vois comme quoi un jour vous
êtes devant une vitrine de disque à
Luxembourg il y a une vendeuse qui vous
dit tiens je vous fais écouter un
morceau c'est numéro 1 en Allemagne ça
s'appelle adios à mort voilà vous
l'écoutez vous le faites et vous en
vendez 500 000 et tout recommence les
sorties
cette chanson là voici ces mots et moi
ma connaissance je vais dire les fait du
plaisir elle est engagée pour l'été elle
vend ses disques vas-y achète lui ce
disque j'écoute ce disque allemand je le
mets
ça me laisse de marbre je le ramène chez
moi je l'écoute et je me dis mais c'est
pas vrai mais quel tube énorme et là
j'ai dû me battre avec les paroliers qui
disait oui ça fait chelou c'est pas bien
le producteur qui n'aimait pas les
Allemands on donne pas d'autorisation et
moi je dis d'écouter faites ce que vous
voulez je l'enregistre et je l'envoie
fini et là il me donne l'autorisation et
c'est un coup de tonnerre
et je j'entends encore les paroles de ce
directeur de maison de disque qui me dit
nous sommes en train de reconquérir la
France comme la gauche elle est bonne là
on vient de le voir la légende de
Frédéric François
maintenant on va casser votre image on
va faire une interview vous êtes à mon
image vous êtes capable
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous connaissez des gros mots
oui vous dites quoi comme gros mots bien
la vérité je n'ai jamais juré de ma vie
mais quand je jure c'est toujours
court nous dit
la boutique oh [__] ça veut rien dire
c'est le diable est cocu et cette
bouteille c'est une [__]
mais c'est une façon à moi de me
dégager c'est quoi vos défauts pour
casser votre image et des défauts quand
même vous avez pas que des qualités
c'est quoi vos défauts je suis
bordélique je suis des vrais défauts
[Rires]
un peu comme Olivier
on a tous à penchant pour les personnes
un peu âgées un vrai défaut non mais
c'est des défauts
je sais pas moi si j'ai des défauts oui
macho tiens allez très mature vous êtes
capable de
ah non non la femme je la porte comme un
diamant dans le creux de ma main non non
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça mais
mais ce côté sicilien fait que ça coule
dans les veines et que mais c'est
toujours très gentil par exemple je vais
rentrer un exemple et ma femme se
tracasse pour savoir ce qu'elle va me
préparer elle va lui je vais préparer à
me dire non surtout pas elle me prépare
et tout est-ce que c'était bon oui tu
veux un peu plus oui
maintenant tu vas me mettre dans le
fauteuil je vais t'apporter un café mais
tout ça c'est de l'amour en fait c'est
pas cesser de Mathieu est-ce que vous
pourriez dire pour casser votre image
que vous êtes un obsédé sexuel
écoutez je vais vous avouer un truc les
musiciens ne me croient pas mais quand
on vous envoie 10000 watts dans les
oreilles de haute fréquence vous devez
si tu l'entends
médicalement tu deviens obsédé sexuel ah
c'est pour ça que tous les musiciens
sont un peu à la neige c'est pour ça
donc vous êtes un obsédé sexuel
oui parce que
c'est le premier stage le deuxième stade
où sombrer dans dans une déprime
terrible et puis c'est la folie et moi
j'ai dû au médecin écoutez moi je
préfère rester dans le premier stade
d'accord sexuel est-ce que vous pourriez
révéler un horrible scoop sur votre
jeunesse pour casser votre image un truc
terrible que vous avez fait à
l'adolescence
qu'est-ce que j'ai pu faire de quand
vous avez pas violer une fille avec des
copains dans les corons non
le fantasme sur le charbon encore chaud
tu vois
[Rires]
je sais pas pour casser notre image
est-ce que vous pourriez vous coiffer
autrement par exemple oui regardez les
faisceaux du lit un peu fait voir
ça change tout
c'est incroyable
on essaie de casser un peu notre image
est-ce que vous pourriez faire un doigt
tous les gens qui vous aiment pas non
si c'est pour la bonne cause
en public vas-y
non
pour ceux qui vous aiment pas pour ceux
qui vous aiment pas ce qui vous déteste
ceux qui disent c'est un pauvre con
allez-y
fait
du mal de Michel Sardou cet [__]
écoutez j'ai écrit pour Michel Sardou
parce que c'est important que les gens
le sachent une chanson qui s'appelait
Domenico et à un moment donné il
chantait en italien et alors par respect
bien sûr je
suis allé le voir et depuis ce jour là
je me suis dit tu iras jamais plus voir
personne il avait pas été sympa avec
vous vous a mal traité exactement moi en
tant que sicilien j'aime le respect
l'accueil donc c'était peut-être pas
dans ces coutumes voilà
c'est vrai
est-ce que vous pourriez insulter les
flics là il y en a eu quelques [__]
mais je roulais un peu plus vite que
d'habitude
[Rires]
et que le reste le reste c'est que des
filles de passage
[Applaudissements]
avec des yeux
bon il m'arrête bien vous savez combien
pour relier vous avez dépassé la vitesse
il me dit vous savez que je vous ai
reconnus j'aime beaucoup vos chansons je
me barakato tu es sauvé et là il sort
son carnet il dit voilà j'ai verbalisé
Salvatore Adamo celui-là celui-là il me
manquait plus que vous dans ma
collection
tu imagines donc c'est un [__] tu es
d'accord mais c'est [__] dans la
mesure où il y avait deux maghrébins
sympathiques en taxi qui était en
infraction et qui devait payer
directement et qui m'ont dit Monsieur
Frédéric faites-moi plaisir nous n'avons
pas l'argent vous pouvez pas nous payer
le PV et j'ai payé deux PV ce jour-là
c'est sympa
alors
est-ce que pourriez-vous lécher
l'oreille d'un mec pour casser le
fromage après il y a les couilles fais
gaffe
non j'adore lécher les oreilles je
trouve que c'est non mais attendez même
pas
[Applaudissements]
de sensualité et que c'est très
important et bien sûr ça fait partie de
tous les préliminaires elle est d'accord
elle est d'accord pour ça
attention
écoutez la première fois que je viens
faire cette émission et demain je
divorce non quand même pas mais menu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens Thierry les gens le font chez
eux
que c'est très agréable les chats
d'oreilles
de Thierry lever la main alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est très excitant oui
très très excitant et la nuque plus
intéressant la langue dans l'oreille
ok on peut continuer tout va bien alors
toujours pour casser votre image est-ce
que vous avez déjà demandé de l'argent
pour chanter dans une œuvre caritative
je viens de faire un festival rock vous
demandez pas d'argent quand c'est
caritatif
complètement défoncé
au contraire j'ai fait un festival rock
c'était la fête de l'espoir
et je me retrouvais à côté à table avec
magmatah avec MC Solaar avec un goon
mais non mais tu t'es pas fait payer
quoi comme c'était caritatif c'est
dommage c'est vrai ce que tu mets une
belle chambre une question là où tu peux
peut-être vraiment casser ton image
Frédéric allez je vais essayer est-ce
que tu as déjà trompé ta femme
tout le monde rigole et tout le monde
rigole j'aime ma femme
non pourquoi je vais la tromper
de femmes je me suis dit que de femmes
est-ce que tu as déjà saccagé une
chambre d'hôtel avec ta femme
oui oui un vrai rockeur oui
attends c'est quoi pour toi
tu es parti à midi 2
j'ai pris la chaise je l'ai cassé je
retourné tout non mais ça tu n'étais pas
seul mais
juste à casser une chaise c'est tout et
le lit
casser votre image est-ce que vous avez
déjà touché à l'homosexualité
et bien jamais de ma vie je vous
décevoir mais je suis rentré dans ce
métier
pur et toujours vierge et la bisexualité
ni même la bisexualité très sexualité ni
la triste sexualité non 30 ans de ce
business tu t'es jamais fait [__] si
alors d'une autre façon ah oui dans un
monde de requin vous fait [__]
est-ce que vous avez déjà écrit nos
futurs quelque part comme ça mon fils
Anthony pas moi mais mon fils atomique
dans mon garage est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu votre sang
histoire
Olivier
c'est bizarre
et tout dans les cérémonies en
sicilement et alors là ça descend de
frère la mafia quoi non mais un peu
quand même l'amitié
Frédéric est-ce que vous avez déjà porté
des menottes ailleurs que dans un
commissariat avez-vous vous voulez dire
dans un lit
ben non oui c'est un fantasme qui passe
dans la tête de certains hommes mais bon
des fois elles partent avec le
portefeuille avec tout donc c'est mal ah
on voit qu'il a une expérience il l'a
fait à mon avis il l'a fait excusez déjà
porté un string en cuir noir écoutez
j'étais sur la Côte d'Azur et je
commence bien
ça sent le oui
et ma femme pour rigoler
m'avait acheté un string
mais on peut rien mettre là-dedans
en 9 octobre à l'Olympia et en tournée
en partie du 15 octobre
[Applaudissements]
attention la petite carte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous devez faire quelque chose pour la
France c'est bien oui et je suis en
train de faire quelque chose pour la
France
[Applaudissements]
je vais devoir
éliminer un des invités présents ce soir
fait mal j'ai pas invité moi
mais c'est pas grave
bon salut salut
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu